.
THEY NEVER THINK ABOUT THE
GEOPOLITICAL ISSUES THAT ARE
COLLIDING WITH THIS SCENARIO.
CHINESE PRESIDENT SHE IS LEAVING
TO VISIT VLADIMIR PUTIN.
WOULD PRESIDENT XI REALLY BE
BETTING ON A HORSE THAT HE
THINKS IS COLLUDES.
THEY HAVE A BIG SURVEILLANCE
SYSTEM IN CHINA THAT THEY?
WHEN HE LET THAT HAPPEN?
JOINING US IS CONGRESSMAN JIM
BANKS.
THIS ALL BEEN ACCELERATED
CONGRESSMAN BY BIDENS HANDLING
THE RUSSIA AND MIDDLE EAST OVER
TO ENERGY PRODUCTION.
WE ABANDON EVERYTHING WE HAD IN
OUR FAVORITE, AND RUSSIA CAN NOW
RUN THE TABLE.
>> BIDEN IS THE BEST THING
HAPPENING TO RUSSIA.
TWO PEOPLE THANKED BY PUTIN
SHOULD BE GRETA THUNBERG AND
JOE BIDEN.
BECAUSE OF THE DISASTROUS ENERGY
PAUL SEES THAT THEY'VE ENACTED
IN THE NAME OF THE
GREEN NEW DEAL HAS SOLD OUT
AMERICA'S FOREIGN POLICY TO
CHINA.
DONALD TRUMP WAS BUYING OIL AT
$25 OF BAIL STOMACH BARREL FOR
THE PRESERVES, NOW BIDEN WILL BE
$80 A BARREL THAT IS GOING TO
SPEND TO REPLENISH IT AND THE
TAXPAYERS ARE THE ONES WHO ARE
ON THE HOOK FOR IT.
>> Laura: AT THE SAME TIME
THEY WERE COMPLAINING AND ONE OF
THE OTHER NETWORKS TODAY, THE
ALL COMPANY EXECUTIVES HAVE TO
EXPLAIN WHETHER MAKING SO MUCH
MONEY.
DO THEY NOT UNDERSTAND THE LAW
OF SUPPLY AND DEMAND?
WHEN USE SHRINK SUPPLY, THIS CAN
BE A LOT MORE PEOPLE GOING FOR
THAT BARREL OF OIL.
HOW IS IT SO COMPLICATED FOR
THEM?
>> THE DEMOCRATS DON'T GET IT IN
BIDEN IS RESPONSIBLE AND RUSSIA
IS EMBOLDENED.
>> Laura: FOR THE FIRST TIME
SINCE COVID, PRESIDENT SHE IS
MEETING FOR THE FIRST TIME AFTER
COVID WITH PUTIN AT THIS POINT
IN THE RUSSIA AND UKRAINE
CONFLICT.
>> WERE IN A CRITICAL STAGE
RIGHT NOW.
THE FILL THUNDER ROAD CHART CAN
ALWAYS STAGE ONE.
THAT FAILED.
AND THEN WE WENT INTO A WAR OF
ATTRITION.
UKRAINE IS FIGHTING HEROICALLY
BUT THEY'RE GETTING VERY CLOSE
TO THE RUSSIAN BORDER AND THAT
RAISES THE QUESTION THAT YOU
HAVE AN AILING DICTATOR WITH
7,000 NUCLEAR WEAPONS, THE
WORLD'S LARGEST ARSENAL.
THERE ARE SCENARIOS WE DON'T
THINK ABOUT.
IF YOU JUST GET TO SAY, I LOST A
HUNDRED THOUSAND DEAD WOUNDED OR
MISSING PEOPLE, WE LOST, AND TO
QUIT.
I DON'T THINK SO.
IS HE TO KEEP IT AND BLEED OUT
CHRIS McDONALD THINK SO.
IS HE GOING TO SAY THAT IT'S A
REAL WAR, NOT A SPECIAL MILITARY
OPERATION?
I DON'T THINK SO.
HE SEES THAT UKRAINIANS ARE
GETTING CLOSE TO THE BORDER,
ATTACKING SHIPS AND WERE BACK TO
1962 WHEN IT'S GOOD TO DO
SOMETHING DRAMATIC.
WE THINK HE WOULDN'T DARE DO
THAT.
BUT THAT BEGS THE QUESTION, IS
NEW TO MAC UKRAINE THE NATO
NUCLEAR UMBRELLA?
SOME WITH THE ADMINISTRATION AND
SOME AFFILIATED OR INDEPENDENT
ACT AS IF IT IS.
THEY THINK WERE OBLIGED TO
DEFEND UKRAINE IN SOME SCARY
FASHION IF RUSSIA DOES SOMETHING
STUPID.
SO I THINK THE CHINESE AND THE
RUSSIANS ARE FIGURING OUT WHAT
IS THE NEXT STEP, AND COULD BE
VERY SCARY ALONG THE LINES OF
THE 1962 CUBAN MISSILE CRISIS.
WE NEED TO TAKE IT DEEP BREATH
BEFORE THE MIDTERMS BECAUSE
THINGS ARE ACCELERATING.
WHAT ARE OUR RESPONSIBILITIES?
WHAT ARE THE DANGERS TO THE
UNITED STATES PEOPLE?
THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE TO ASK.
>> Laura: ARE AMERICAN PEOPLE
READY TO GO TO NUCLEAR WAR IN
DEFENSE UKRAINE?
YES OR NO.
I WOULD GUESS THE ANSWER TO THE
QUESTION IS NO.
AS MUCH THEY WANT UKRAINE TO
WIN, THEY'RE GOING TO SAY NO.
HE IS AN ISSUE THAT WAS BROUGHT
UP AT THE WHITE HOUSE TODAY.
JOHN KIRBY TRIED TO ADJUST IT
BUT NOT REALLY.
>> GIVEN THE FACT THAT UNKNOWN
ADVERSARY IN THE CASE OF CHINA,
FOREIGN BUYERS ARE BUYING UP
U.S. REAL ESTATE, SOMETIMES
FIRMS AROUND THE U.S.
IS US ON THE READER?
>> IT'S OUT OF MY SWIM LANE A
LITTLE BIT.
I'M PROBABLY NOT THE RIGHT
PERSON TO ASK ABOUT THAT.
>> Laura: CONGRESSMAN I FOUND
THAT ANSWERED TO BE INSULTING
AND APPALLING.
THAT MAN HAS NO ANSWER FOR CHINA
BUYING FARMLAND IN THE
UNITED STATES?
>> IT SHOULD BE OUTLAWED.
IT SHOULD BE OUTLAWED TO STOP
CHINA FROM BUYING FARMLAND AND
PROPERTIES.
IT SHOULD BE BANNED.
THE WHITE HOUSE STILL TO THIS
POINT THIS DAY REFUSES TO
COACH MINTER AND EVER SIZE
STOMACH ADVERSARY IT'S CRIMINAL
THAT THEY CONTINUE TO IGNORE IT.
>> Lau